m
good evening
members officers
[Music]
apologies for absence
thank you chad cancer brenton councillor
helpful councilman mckenzie councillor
watson councilman newton councillor dark
and councillor ranch
[Music]
item two is the central minutes of the
18th of july 22 and the extraordinary
meeting held on august the 8th we take
the uh
8th the 18th of july first of all
we've all been circulated with someone
after the program
all in favor please sure
and again
and abstentions
thank you
and moving on to the eighth of august
extraordinary minutes
[Music]
after
show
on begins
on any abstentions
okay thank you very much
okay moving on to item three actually
this which is on page 14.
[Music]
yeah
about the nhs and writing about the
minor injuries um that's right just know
that we had to write again on the 10th
it's now nearly a month since that was
written um
my last name
um
i
earth but then they can suggested for
something
um it's just not on but we shouldn't get
a response
so about two months ago
[Music]
okay
and then let me get some news so we need
to
vote
we're just going to thank you
after four public contributions we have
one speaker this is on a friend from red
earth
we wish to speak on titan 13
so you've got
three minutes and when you start to
speak i will give you a prompt
about 15 seconds from the end to let you
know that you need to wind up that's
okay yeah it shouldn't be
three minutes
uh chair thank you for the opportunity
to speak to agenda item 13. i'm simon
friend and my company redder is the
owner of brunswick war
this vital regeneration scheme will
bring over 25 million of investment into
the town
i felt compelled to come this evening
because there are areas in the report
which give a misleading impression which
i must address
firstly there's an erroneous subjective
statement that redder could at some
point sell off the site at a value far
in excess of the purchase price
i can assure you i have no intention of
doing that and in any event that
planning your council's own independent
valuation report
stated that even with the benefit of the
grant the land value was negative
negative 1.5 million secondly it's
suggested that redder will use the
funding to provide a more rudimentary
scheme
that is simply not the case
the specification we've now agreed
between us will provide a significant
enhancement to the key wall
thirdly there's a suggestion that red
earth will start the keyboard works now
even without the grant
i have stated very clearly to your
officers that if the grant is not
available or new conditions prove to be
onerous the keyboard works will be
delayed and included in the scope for
the main construction contract as and
when that is agreed
with still no news it's becoming
inevitable that the works will be
delayed
under the contract responsibility for
ensuring the keyword does not
deteriorate further pending start of
those works remains firmly with the
council
i must address the grant funding
the grant was made february 2021 on
various conditions all of which have
been complied with indeed it was
reported to full council in september 21
that there was no financial risk of
grant clawback
with a legitimate expectation of
delivery of the grant i commenced
detailed site investigations and design
development tended the works and
negotiated with the contractor to start
in july this year
however 17 months after confirmation of
the grant and less than two weeks prior
to start on site i received an email
from council officers stating that new
and further conditions for the grant
were to be imposed
i still do not know what those
conditions are
i fully appreciate that the council
cannot put itself in a position of
financial clawback risk
but week by week i've had to delay the
start of works whilst i await details of
those conditions
this is hugely disruptive to the whole
project
to expediate the grant offer redder
offered an indemnity to repay the grant
if the housing is not built i've had no
response to that offer
finally
i remain completely committed to this
project
i hope we can resolve this grant
conditions issue because it's in the
best interest of all parties to do so
let's work together to get this done for
the benefit of biddeford and the people
who live
thank you
thank you mr friend thank you very much
iphone 5 on your agenda is declarations
of interest so members of an interest
should declare that
relevant uh gender item when it comes up
item six is the agreement of gender
items uh part one and two
uh department where there are no part
two
item seven to consider correspondence or
any other business
especially
by the direction of the chair
i would just like to
offer my personal congratulations to
david jones that i understand has
recently qualified as an assistant
i'm
to answer questions submitted under
procedure rule a9
such questions have been submitted
nine update on the of the medium term
financial strategy pages 16 to 25 on
your
agenda um david haynes is going to
present them
thank you
first slide
please okay
so this is the recap where we were back
in february of 2022 i came before you
and of course some meetings and
financial strategies at that time
we were reportedly following the
following use of the challenging
government problem with the balance our
revenue company so in
2022-23 the current financial year we've
forecasted
using 373 000 from reserves for balance
of budgets riding to six hundred and
twenty nine thousand and twenty three
twenty four in decline in survive 26 27
we had a semblance of the budgets being
in balance
so we just
imagine the transition in government
funding deserves our building society
count but we did think soon when we're
not in a balanced position
we should only really use the transition
in government funding to allow time
decisions to make to bring council-based
budgets back into balance
at the time i reported to you in
february 2022 the social utilization
translation government funding reserves
to get to the 1.4 million leading the
balance on the reserve 274 000 at the
end of the immediate financial trial
because there is
which have been overtaken by events
um that when i made that uh doesn't say
this back in february first my council
tax would increase by up to the right
branding limit which is roughly 2.8 a
year
the pay award would be two percent per
annum for the duration of the need and
so financial strategy
sorry's council support for lego would
be 450 000 pounds by 25.26
uh we increased the planning income side
by smoothing 50 000 and i made a
projection that incomplete broken bodies
would return to pre-pandemic levels by
25.26 at the next slide please come
so you've got a chart below you which
show you on the very left-hand side in
pale yellow the 2020 monster
under 1.7 million pounds
and the next chart
lights blue to the left of the black
line
isn't the current deficit
as you can see we've had a significant
change in circumstances we have to give
perspective counselors our gross spend
excluding health and benefits in the
region 15 to 16 million pounds so why
the world
moved so
adversely against the council
well in
2021-22 we were still getting some
residual coverage related funding but
all the extra work we didn't
business support graphs well that's
largely seasonal
temporary accommodation would be
referred to later in the presentation if
we call our particularly pressing issue
obviously with the examination of our
previous contract with 1610 for legend
and was uh deliberately by a local
authority home training company to
support the levy increase
the 2020 to 23 pay award was not 2
planning income
we're achieving a new target but we're
not achieving the levels that we did in
the prior year
that's not no surprise for anybody here
fuel and utility costs have vastly
increased for the council and isn't
possible that expanded suppression
so why are we facing a financial crisis
if i made it simple
it's a housing crisis and it's inflation
there are the two factors of play
i'll now go through so much liquid
regarding the housing crisis
in meeting our staff obligations with
president of risk of homelessness the
council is facing increasing challenges
in the absence of affordable sustainable
tendencies the council is facing an
increasing financial burden of placing
people in temporary accommodation
our report that went to our colleagues
at devon county council in september
2021
reported a 70 decrease in privately
owned rental properties
in the last two years across denver and
that's largely possibly explained by the
rise in holiday accommodation across
canada
the next slide it's really showing what
average earnings have done since 2018-19
with an estimate of two point up to 2022
and to put stimuli
in
1819 monthly take on poke the average of
1738 pounds and 2022.23
1933 that's an increase of 11 percent
however the average two bed rental has
gone up from 550 a 785 increase of 42
and rent as a percentage of people's
take-home pay have visited from 32 to 40
percent so put simply
take home pay is only written by 11
whilst rents are driven by 42 rents are
increasingly becoming unaffordable for a
cohort of our residents
not surprising we're dealing with more
people presenting themselves at risk of
homelessness
in 2019 20 we have 22 without dealing
with approximately 70 households that's
more than one person
a whole household can consist of an
individual
[Music]
fundamentally the demand for temporary
accommodation has increased at the same
time prices have increased so with this
dedication the prices of holiday
accommodating caravans etc has increased
and they're the top two lines that you
can see in the top chart
whilst what the cost that we've
recovered with the local housing
allowance would basically remain static
so in a perfect stone we've got
increased demand the way we meet the
demand values attack accommodation old
costs have gone up and we're getting no
further compensation through the housing
benefits it could be the local housing
allowance
the charts at the bottom of the
homelessness cost of the council the
blue is what we can stand in and
underneath which is slightly faded from
the red is our budget and you can see
from 1819 1920 2022 and 21 22 it started
to accelerate we were roughly spending
the budget
spend has just gone up exponentially
okay so we've covered the housing crisis
the other issue we're facing and
everybody in this room is based until
after the greater effect is inflation
at the time we set the budget back in
2000 in february 2022
inflation would become an increase in
concern however
russian and vegan of the ukraine has
seen inflation at levels not to mention
the mid-1977
like every other organization for their
challenge and inflation both not with
the payload
fuel which fueled our revenue please the
utility the gas and the electric and
construction price inflation as the
city's single biggest item expenditure
inflation requested with respect to pay
awards have a very significant impact on
the council's financial viability
so just to give some context
the council remember the local
government association and his
collective pay bargaining with the
unions
so we don't individually eventually
mitigate the pay award that
and the employers offered
furthermore the expected impact of
increases to beginner and living wage
so it says back to probably that will
announce in october what the minimum
wage will be from the first of april
2023 and it's expected that's going to
go viral
so the minimum living wage is probably
9.50
absolutely
[Music]
so
we've actually do all this to our local
authority salary scales we've gone to
some of our lower pay scales
incompatible with minimum living wage
legislation though our hands are forced
largely on the aor
i think we need to acknowledge when
we're discussing the budgets
that responding to the financial
pressures based by inflation the council
is very limited in its response that
they operate in a regulatory environment
so a supermarket will have rising input
prices and to a large degree they can
simply pass them on to the consumer
we're not so fortunate
council tax were limited by the
referendum i don't mention dearly a lot
the referendum limits are five pound per
vandy which equates to about 2.8 percent
inflation is currently 10.1 for cpi i
think 12.1 for rpr
business rates
but we don't set the business rates we
collect business rates the rates in the
pound is set by
the valuation of the business is set by
the valuation of this
government grants
we are the recipient of the government
grant but we don't determine the level
of government grants
so the other area with some discretion
is fees and charges
and a circular about 50 percent of our
fees and charges are step-by-step for
example planning application things
so when we have full discretion on our
fees and charges it only equates about
19 to 20 of our growth income so the
only thing we could actually influence
in terms of our income
is 20 of our income
that's why i please tom
so you have before you were table
showing the latest financial projections
before the recommendations of an
underbudget working group
so if you look at the left-hand columns
of 2022-23
we were
anticipating using
373 000 of our budgets to balance
and forgetting a deficit against a
budget of 1.26 million
which means we will be using to balance
the books for 2013. 1.6 million of our
reserves uh balancing our transition
government found in the birth of april
2022 with over 2 million and that would
only leave us 378 000 in the building
society council speed
then you go into 2023-24
[Music]
and i'm forecasting i'm going to need to
use 1.7 million pounds for the
transition in government funding
well clearly i don't have 1.7 million
pounds in the transition in government
funding to reserve the balance
so by the end of the meeting financial
strategy
we've got a recurrent deficit of 866
thousand pounds per year and we would
have accumulated for one of the better
experts in overdraft
so the next slide
incorporates both the recommendations of
the
budget working group and also
repurposing some of the reserve
essentials on the reserve that we've
decided we probably can do without and
the need whether it may be expired or
just something that we don't have the
resources to deliver
and as you can see there
still you want three hundred and seventy
three thousand but it sits for you the
forecast over spending 1.26 million
uh i'll repurpose the reserve of 550
profiles it gets down to a deficit of a
million
so it leaves us with a million pounds in
the transition government
[Music]
and then obviously hopefully the
recommendations and then the work will
be very accepted
and then you see the position is
we still have an issue with the balance
of budgets for 23 to 24 they'll overdraw
by 341
if you go to
2026-27
and it says subtotal usage and the
transition government funded over the
right-hand side you should figure 162
what i'm saying at that point
we've got a recurrent deficit of 162 000
and i would have been overdrawn at that
point by 1.36 million
so the next slide
the left-hand side did before it's that
different recommendations of the member
budget working group
and the right-hand side is after records
accepted recommendations of the member
budget working group and as you can see
the blue columns identify the annual
deficit
and the yellow is the cumulative deficit
then you can see it's a vast improvement
but we've still got a long way to go
we're still not there
so to sum up
we're clearly facing exceptional
financial challenges we cannot assume
there's a white knight in the father
increased government funding will appear
on the horizon to this day today as the
section 151 officer hired to make my
projections based on the information
available to them
there are unfortunately some decisions
to be made in order to bring the
council's finances back into balance
ongoing action is needed over the life
of this council and the next in order
for the council to provide services
through defendants
um
we can't put our head in the sound
basically what we're saying
uh we can go to the next slide the
recommendations
at this point just let's hand over to
council hudson agrees
thank you david it's very
solid reading this
uh we have a huge uh hill to find here
but this is the start of
but i think uh our 151 officer has laid
out very clearly for us
and i would like to recommend to you all
that we accept these recommendations
and note the content of the report
thank you for that claire so we've got a
recommendation a proposal to have a
secondary
cancer james all in favor please show
and support that recommendation
and against
um
yours again
okay
yeah would you just read those outside
sorry do you recommend
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
four
two against and six abstentions
[Music]
right on
[Music]
to report back to members to reduce
college's financial deficit i understand
that
you're going to present the report and
there you've just appeared before me as
if by magic yes um
it's a pity i haven't got any magic but
tonight i'm
have the honor of presenting this report
on behalf of the members budget working
group
this group have worked tirelessly with
the support of our
section one python officer our chief
exec
to look and examine
our budgets to see where we can make
substantial savings
to actually meet the deficit
it seemed only fair that this was a
members working budget group that a
member should be presenting this report
um so that is why i'm here before you as
a member of that group and the lead
member for finance
call council uh
we got the first slide up yeah thank you
um
appointed and agreed on the 21st of
february to establish a member budget
working group
and it was a cross-party membership
the first meeting was held
and i had the next slide where we
determined what the remit of the group
would be it was to minimize the chance
of redundancies
that proposals should be brought to full
council within a reasonable framework
and we will prioritize raising
additional income
over cuts to services
most importantly leisure would not be
debated at that time
because we had already agreed at full
council to await a report that would be
presented to us in the autumn
and everyone had accepted that
so leisure was some parked to one side
the work of this group will continue and
it was agreed at this first meeting
throughout the life of this council
next slide please
the following areas have been reviewed
by the members working group
um they're all listed here
so i think that's quite clear and within
the report you've actually had the
itemized details about what
it would add to our savings
all right next slide please
this now actually itemizes
um
the amount of savings that we can make
from car parking
through to council uh treasury
management council tax premiums the
legislation for this we do not benefit
from this until 24 25
because we cannot claim
the uh increased amount for second hand
until that period
these decisions are difficult
they're not they haven't been um
considered lightly
there's been much debate and each of the
groups within this council has
contributed and worked together
if
we
re
reject these proposals
life will become much more unpalatable
if we cannot make this initial stab of
making
something towards the savings that we
will have to achieve
the decisions may be taken out of our
hands and as members
you will be dictated to because if we
can't set a balanced budget
we will lose that control
this isn't a threat it's just a
statement of fact
that if we haven't got a balanced budget
we will not be allowed to proceed
some of you will may feel that some of
the elements as in
one member grants is a difficult one
because member grants are used to help
our constituents in our parishes
however i will point out to you that
declan county council had been much more
radical
and
ended counselor grants
not reduce them ended them
we have actually returned to a thousand
pounds per member
which was the amount that was given to
members
before we enjoyed
new homes bonus
when a previous council decided that
some of that would be awarded to
councillors to actually
share out within their communities
that was when times were good
times are much more difficult and much
more challenging now
so that is the reason we've decided to
keep it
to the 1000 we're not ending it
completely but the recommendation is
that it'd be reduced by 50 percent
can i have
an exchange please
right you can see the long and winding
road i think uh you can imagine that
i've had some help with these slides and
you probably detect the artwork from
our section 151 officer
the long rewinding road
we are on a journey we started it
this group will continue to meet and
will return here in december
with another range of proposals
the members working group will examine
every aspect that we can make savings
because we need to find
250 000
in budget savings
and
350 000
to produce a balanced budget for 23.24
we're not giving up we're on this is
phase one of a long journey
so
next slide please
i would like therefore
to move the recommendations
listed
here
that we approve the car parking charges
we approve the increase for vehicular
access to northern boroughs
we reduce member grants to 1000 per
elected member
we agree the changes to the
discretionary rate relief policy
remove discretionary rate relief to
village halls now
village halls get all these that
i think i need to expand on this at a
title
uh if you haven't picked it up in the
report
all these people get 80
relief
and that is statutory they get that
we
voluntarily award a further 20
and we are saying that in these times we
cannot afford to continue to do this
um but it will be phased out
by five percent per annum effected from
the first of april 23 so people have got
time to
make up the amounts that they're
uh having to find
now these are not enormous sums
and um i know councillor christie will
want to say something with regard to
that and he will fill you in on
the funding aspects of it
finally to increase garden waste charges
to 52 pounds
and to agree today
to additional council tax premiums for
empty homes which we can introduce
in the financial year
24
25
so that is the set of recommendations
which i wholeheartedly commend to you
um
any questions
that's a lot first and then come to the
pen
yeah i am
a member of the working group and it's
been very interesting and such decisions
to make but in the meeting where we
discussed members grants i had admitted
that i was against
the grants being reduced to a thousand
pounds
um because in rural areas and i've got
eight villages in my parish and i know
lots of rural members a thousand pounds
won't go very far
for each organization
so i was going to answer a
recommendation that that is put up back
up to 2 000 pounds but on hearing what
perhaps the hudson has said with regard
to devon county council scrapping
community grants all together
i will support the recommendation to
reduce it to a thousand
thank you councilmember
um i've seen we get 26 percent of our
income from business rates in the future
before just to say i abstained on the
previous motion because there was no to
know
and i think we should have had a freedom
to ask questions and break wonder this
item agenda that we can ask questions
how bulletproof are we given the impact
of certain businesses facing fill here
now this winter and what impact will it
have on our budget um when you look at
this from the member
working room please ultimately of course
the business rate is the owner of the
premises just liable for business rates
so so it was a shock that i'm profiling
from a landlord so the landlord becomes
liable there for the business rights
they will of course please come back in
any recession there's an increase in bad
debts
but what
the situation they're already thinking
there will be reduce in income from
business rates
this winter before we come even to the
next financial year probably not
this not this year now
what i'm saying i can't tell you
what businesses will before
okay but generally of course
the business rates are on ultimately if
it's not tenanted and not occupied it
will retire from the owner but there's
somebody
but our central government has been
awarded the last six weeks it seems
uh
um
thank you for allowing me to ask
questions thank you councilman captain
hanks thank you mr chairman whilst i
agree with the principles
pretty well everything council hudson
says
there's one thing i cannot agree to
and that is the reduction of business
rates on village halls
if you come out into the rural wars
it's about the only thing we get from
torrents other than the rubbish
collection
and you're cutting it out now why hit
the rural villages
if you're going to hammer rural villages
go into the towns not something out of
them they don't have village halls i
have convenient events but i'm not
voting for it because
thank you president thank you councillor
hits
a very pat impassioned supporter for
village halls
i think
because it is 20
we are not cutting the relief completely
they get 80
relief
20
is
not a huge amount of funding i
understand your anxiety about this but
we have said in the uh budget working
group
that we would um do this as a tapered
um
i'm being presented with information so
i can uh
tell you village halls um
on average it's about 200 pounds
per year
that is what they're going to have to
find
it's which is very clear it's up to 200
percent or that's the 200 pounds for the
20
david's just given me the cost to the
authority
and showing what uh they would have to
find
um
and it ranges from some smaller places
just over a hundred pounds to two
hundred
pounds
also made the observation that a lot of
village halls are connected with parish
councils but parish councils have no
limits on their precept so the paris
council wants to support a village hall
they have the option of doing it by
raising their feet they're not capped at
the counselling by referential limits
and i would also point out that during
coverage
that that majority of billy charles also
receive um coal with related grants so
have a in the last couple of years quite
a lot of village halls have had quite
significant financial windfall to be
truthful
reported that yes
number one cove has been and gone as far
as the payments were concerned they're
not getting any more but you put in
their charges
parish councils can subsidize the very
top
council consumption by their faith
there is no difference if why should the
rural areas be average and not the
herbal markets
any other speakers
well i think
i just agree with everything he says
that's about readers
[Music]
so if it's only going to affect the
rules
no you haven't got confused there are
other halls that are attracting this
uh discretionary 20 percent really
cousin james you wanted swimming yeah i
was just going to bangkok to hotman i
chaired the working group
i have to say it's not been fun um as
the other members of the group know that
we are in a situation where we have to
play reality i'm actually i've got nine
characters
and for
15 20 years i've been chair of the
council continually raising money for it
and when it was bankrupt i actually paid
the bills myself to get out of trouble
[Music]
they get together they raise money
um and i'm afraid
it's the reality i'm not i support the
uh
christian before we move on
[Music]
want to do the best for our people but
we have to be pragmatic we are faced
with some real problems
however and i argued this long and hard
at the committee meetings
um many of us have supported our food
banks
on both on a personal basis and also
with our council of grants
but i would like to see torres
supporting the food banks within
torridge on a corporate basis as well
it's actually the figure is not large
but i think it shows that
torridge cares
because the food banks are at the
cutting edge of what our population is
facing and i would like to make an
addition to the recommendations so it'd
be 6.7
in the light of the current economic
crisis i propose an addition
that food banks within torridge are
covered by alternative equivalent
funding delivered by the council
so we would actually be covering that 20
for our food banks
i'm going to do is a second as much
and as the proposal i'm more than happy
to accept that addition
but good proposed
can accordingly
[Music]
i think the working group have come up
with some very good
ideas here
and there are some things here which
have we've got to do them it's very
clear in circumstances we're in we have
no option
i think what's important as we move
forward is to ensure that we keep
everything on the table when we're
looking at ways to make savings whether
that's
increasing some of these fees further
whether that's looking at our leisure
provision
our discretionary services or the
council's own structure we have to look
at everything and we can't shy away we
cannot be squeamish
the only question that i
had in addition was
i said i'm not part of the working group
and i'm not a northern councillor
can i ask why the
feed for the northern boroughs day
tickets certainly gone up by a pound
um to six pounds when to park in the
main car park in there during the summer
season is going to be 12 or 14
would it not make sense for them to be
more on par
um it just seems like it's quite a
discount just to sort of walk around the
corner and park at the boroughs rather
than parking in the main car park i was
just wondering if there's any logic
behind that
that's the laws
shot up straight away
give me time to think that one out thank
you counselor
thank you chair
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's going to be six pounds rather
than 12 or 14 pounds
so it
i i fully appreciate what you're saying
council the laws that you're not getting
much of your real money but
you could say at the same time this is
just the general car park so i just it
just seemed that there was quite a
disparity there and i wondered if that
was
an easy couple of pounds that we could
put on
there
at least in the summer season perhaps
okay we just bring sean and he's eager
again
i will say now chair just wanted to
point out that when you you the the
charge for the burroughs is a toll to
enter the country park and not car
parking child so we just need to clarify
that the other thing i think to just to
point out and i don't necessarily
disagree that there might be some room
for maneuver in future years and
probably a future proposal to increase
that that charge that toll um you do
have the hourly tariff in the car park
so you didn't have to pay your 12 pounds
you could literally stay to two three
four hours as you wish to live in charge
that's the board
yeah thank you
yeah actually just declined by
mourinho's technically actually in my
world
certainly majority of it actually i
might not want a veteran authority
and as they were a young councillor he's
very probably got this to lift their
qualification which i'm very pleased he
has but you should be aware you keep
each case on a merits
basic world
and no one is unique you don't get a lot
of bang for your bucks out there so
unless you go out there and see
question powerful you can't really make
a one-in-form judgment so i reckon the
increase is right at this stage but
everything needs to be left on the table
for reviewing online investment
well i think i would tend to agree with
that question
can i just come back and you know round
up some of the comments that have been
made the members working budget group
will continue
to examine all
avenues for increased
savings
and will welcome any contributions from
any member who thinks we should be
considering a particular issue
so please contact either the chair
uh councillor james or indeed myself or
um the member that represents your group
to bring forward those things to be
tabled for discussion
no
nothing is off limits
we will look and examine everything but
by virtue of it being a group
we can actually explore things in a lot
more detail than we can do exploring
them when we've got everybody here but
we will bring back and report regularly
to you
coach's hands are going to give you the
last word on this before we take it into
the north
small point about
talking about introducing charging for
northern pool and bone hill
um but there'll be a cost in terms of
installing machines um
that's not going to be which costs when
you
factor that into the savings
are you on the last
so i doubt we'd need to install machines
in there because the tariffs that you
would introduce would probably be done
through part mobile so you could do that
through the telephone call
right okay okay so it's a straight it's
been performed by kevin holden seconded
by councilman christie let me accept the
recommendations can we just repeat 6.7
amendments yes
in light of the current economic crisis
i propose
and addition
dash
that food banks within torridge
are covered
by alternative
equivalent funding
delivered by the council
right it's been proposed and seconded so
i'll put it to the vault and support
and extensions
all right move numbers stack up again
excellent thank you
thank you
oh sorry would you like to just read the
results
sorry
19 for four against and three
abstentions
okay moving on to item 11 on your agenda
updates to the 2223 treasury management
policy which is pages
34-36 and
david i'll call upon you again to
present your report
okay thank you
if you can call the council husband
presentation she listed uh the
recommendations of increased income from
car parking we've got things like
discretionary income
discretionary spend et cetera one of the
things with the trenton environment
concept so technically the changes to
the
so what was actually discussed and
ultimately recommended by the member of
the working group was that we increased
our counterparty release
the maximum 10 million pounds of any one
financial institution
and five million to any one single
lodgement with the financial institution
by having the increased um counterparty
limit
we can actually get a better rate of
return and hence generate more income
from our treasury deposits
the other recommendation
was that another working group
recommended was up to allow the council
for the peer-to-peer lending
uh this would be up to a maximum of one
million pounds and a maximum
of 250 thousand pounds for any one
single investment due to america's
benefit this lending is going to be
secured on land and buildings and the
underlying loan is capped at 60 percent
of the asset value
that current rate one billion will
generate an additional 14 000 pounds of
income and alluding the report to a
higher risk and also
some impacts on the public works
longboard faster so essentially because
public councils
have borrowed money from the public
longboard to invest for
return
and the government is a little bit more
stricter now
so
it would be
deemed inappropriate if we borrow four
million pounds from the public works
longboard and immediately then just
reinvested that in something which gave
us a higher rate of return because we've
just been borrowing for investment
so we wouldn't send only to you
basically lending after we've drawn down
any funding
for uh say the environment center and
also one is such a
small limit on peer-to-peer lending
because we then argue with peter will be
that this lending would clearly curse
our treasury management and not
primarily driven by
increased returns
um i'll have to take any questions but
this does only need to be voted on
hills
thank you
it's separate to this in a way but i
know previously we agreed that our
investments should be trying to be more
um ethical and environmentally friendly
how much is that decision costing us uh
yeah if we're looking at trying to
squeeze the most we can out i mean at
the moment we're looking because we've
not been able to find a green investment
criteria because we couldn't um point
200
[Music]
and so we've had a few green investments
but when we've gone back out there's no
green investments which made our early
money both as i sit here today the top
of it is zero because we don't have any
green or ethical investment at this
point in time
yes um council raises a very good point
there because um
we have tried for a long time now to get
some equal investments
can i ask that we do continue to look
because
i sit on
two local trusts that we have quite a
lot of money invested uh it's through
the
official investment fund the charities
investment fund funds are different i
know to their market but the ethical
investment
is the second best performing one there
is
and in fact a couple years ago it was
the best
i think we do need to look at this again
so if any do come up can we be informed
them can the officers the restriction we
have of course is that our policy still
says they need to be uk
registered financial institutions with
pitch f1 rating so we've still got that
criteria yes i know that
at some time there has to be one because
the banks out there must realize there
is a demand for this well can we keep
looking that's why yeah as i said every
time my deputy peter does the surgery
management if he can find a green
investment that's within point two of
the percent of the mainstream one then
we will go with that
council
[Music]
can just clarify the we
didn't have that investment
[Music]
um are you saying that the interest rate
went down below our requirements is that
what happened that's correct
well i just
where fossil fuels are another thing we
should be looking in yeah but i was
restrained by african american policy
council and that's what we previously
agreed
cash uh thank you mr chairman
i'm not happy with peer-to-peer lending
it's second-rate lending
you're going to lend to people who are
having difficulty with their existing
banks
um
all right we've had a business called
running very well now for several years
on a rising margin
when the job turns sour it could be
tricky and i really don't think it's the
right thing for a chancellor
any responsibility well they slowed down
in reporters and said
it's late you know they're forbidden
you know the loan to asset ratio is 60
percent of course we've stopped with a
property
all below
losing more than 41 percent of its value
potentially the loneliness that defaults
now i've got to reproduce it yeah that's
what the people ending company did this
canvas decision
you know this is recommendation from the
budget working group
[Music]
one would add you know the rule it's in
the report if you didn't know we don't
want to do that
and don't want to go back and add into
the report as to how it operates
i mean i heard that
we would restrict it to a million
anywhere so we'd only do it on the
fringes of our threatening management
problems the main thing we want to do is
take advantage of having the higher
counterparty limits
and so
that's the main thrust of the
benefit that would be it just gives the
account extra flexibility
can we take each recommendation bullet
points separately
i think the recommendation is that we
take them as a
as a whole thank you
for watching
only accept that i don't remember saying
this before
i can't agree to a single investment of
250.
it's too long i said before i'm sticking
to it as a gambler
thank you thank
yeah you your question yes it's a
question i should have asked the group i
suppose but if we do lend this money is
it
lent on uh property and land within
torridge or are we going elsewhere no
we'd be
well
there wouldn't be any organization that
would
it would work they would just limit
ourselves to college so it generally
would be across the southwest
it's very national
so sorry can i just come back to that
because
i
i tell you council a hit point about
repossessions i mean if if we lend
something to somebody in newcastle
that operates a bit
you don't make it directly to a company
you are lending
that you are investing in a loan
organized by a
facilitator that facilitator when they
do the law they go and
get the asset value the maximum they
will lend is sixty percent of the value
and stood and they
could the company fall into liquid
engine they then realized the asset the
news investor so far i've only got a few
examples
nobody's ever lost and that's no
guarantee the future is for the
facilitating the example we get with the
bulk for them to liquidate the assets
sell the asset and then send some
investors their money and their interest
that is due
i've displayed it out in the report
that's how it works
we're not directly lending to anybody as
such
we don't do the pain we don't have the
resources to do that
we've got the expertise to do that
[Music]
who's
[Music]
psp lending either we want to do it or
we don't want to do it so i think we
just go to the vote and make the
decision we can't keep having reports
coming back and coming back and coming
back so i think we need to make the
decision down right
so i'm sure
we're gonna we're gonna have a vote on
on the whole package
well that's what we've done with the
previous ones and we've uh you know
a variety of bullet points we've got our
advice now from
sorry
i mean my personal preference
this would be one of the members would
be to vote separately because i wouldn't
like to
lose the
increased counterparty with it and the
flexibility that gives them after every
management function
judge holton yes
um i would like to
support the suggestion that we vote on
these two things because separately
because i think it's important that we
actually get the first part
and if there are concerns with regard to
peer-to-peer lending
um we can vote on that section okay
well thank you
so
the recommendations there's two
recommendations the first one is update
the treasury management policy for 22.33
increasing the code of ordinance and 10
million per institutions
[Music]
all in favor please sure
all right
against
and
[Music]
second uh part of the recommendation to
update the treasury management policy in
2023.23
the world prize abuse appeared to be
lending up to a total of one million
pounds for the maximum deal size of 250
thousand
[Music]
this is the peer-to-peer landing what
we've just been discussing
begins
on extensions
[Music]
good potential figures out there
[Music]
thank you
ages 20 sorry 37-42 and
david where you going
okay well i don't intend to go through
the report in any group so just to give
you some brief background
the council adopted the civil code of
practice
the public sector it requires a report
to be presented to the first one on the
traditional activity for the previous
financial year this is what this report
is
i'll just go through the key highlights
and we
basically got exceptionally low income
from our investments after the amount of
investments during the year and that
because the interest rates were so low
and we undertook no new borrowing we did
plan to borrow but the environmental
center has been delayed so we took
no new borrowing and we've made a very
small repayment of debt to the public
what works longer we've redeemed one of
our loans now
i think we've got about 470 000 pounds
with vw get so somewhat concerned about
program management activities
we're not indebted
we don't have any great level of debts
we got low income on our investments
with interest rates were low
so
and i'm just asking members to know the
reports mrs any questions
no need for a vote on this it's just
been nothing but if there are any
questions
no okay thank you
okay moving on to item 13. this is the
bronzing wolf land release fund which is
pages 43
54
[Music]
and
handle sean carly thank you thank you
chair
um members will remember that back in
september 21 we've reported the uh the
award 797 000 grant from uh
for the keeble works of brunswick war
that grant was from the land release
fund the fund managed by the one public
statement program
intended to release land for the use of
for housing use um we
are in constant dialogue with one public
estate uh reporting progress on the
scheme and in those dialogues uh
additional conditionality has been
pointed out to us so the need for
additional conditionality has been
pointed out to us now in essence
uh the primary uh condition of the grant
was that the land was released that
condition has been achieved so the major
risk to the council for grant repayment
and reputation has been achieved but
there does remain the risk that the land
could be used for alternative purposes
and if that were the case one public
estate or dealer could come to the
council and insist on repayment
so
in order to manage that we've asked for
deluxe advice you've heard from mr
friend earlier on about
how we're waiting on their response but
their response is likely to insist or
advise the council to manage its risk
that we indeed we insist on some
additional conditionality in the grant
funding agreement with red earth and
that takes us pretty much to the
recommendation so
that would be to before entering into a
grant agreement with redder for the use
of the 797 lrf brands the conditionality
required by dealer and the one public
estate team is put in place and the
council's position
excuse me throats drying up in relation
to grant clawback is protected prior to
drawing down ground thank you
mr christian
it's um it's very interesting to hear mr
friendly
can i ask on page 45 on our agenda
just about the recommendations the
paragraph there
this is the council speaking we are now
informed that inflationary pressure is
such that the works will cost more than
expected
and the developer will use the funding
to provide a more rudimental scheme now
mr friend directly
contradicted that
what i find odd is that we're all aware
of course when
application
that the cost of that war mr friend had
built in to his costing and his
viability assessment
the
797 000 pounds although it was only 787
on the planning application you've got
10 000 extras
you know that was the sort of bonus that
he didn't expect because i understand
the torridge officer applied for that
and it's suddenly it turned out i'm
i'm very surprised to read now that you
know that's not enough apparently and
yet he had already allowed for that and
i really can't accept that but can i ask
about this rudimental scheme i mean
we're saying one thing he's saying
exactly the opposite which is true so
chair um i think since uh since the
draft of the report was written the
scheme uh design specification has been
agreed with uh red earth um it's not
it's fit for purpose
it meets what's contractually obliged
and i think what had been anticipated
with the use of the funds was that there
would be some additional benefits
provided and those additional benefits
won't be provided and those were things
you know
that we haven't perhaps anticipated in
any of the contract negotiations for in
the planning application uh that because
costs have risen so we are going to get
the key wall which the contractor is
obliged to provide for us
so can i just come back can i ask what
those extra benefits were because
well councillor haines who
leads the
cycling and working cycling working
group walking we've been asking for well
several years now for
a bike track on there that was the only
extra i thought was possible because all
it is is a wall
then a walkway and then his war with his
lots of flats on top so
what are we talking about these
experimenters they were never negotiated
in detail so i can't call him
coastal golf first name council manager
yeah thank you mr uh directed to mr
pioneer straight away from me for the
dluhc and the one public state uh surely
we wait for their comments to come
before the characters before we actually
make a decision i'm not trying to belong
anything here but it is the fact that
we're not releasing this money to
develop a
uh reader
is this prolonging
the development itself because you know
we're going to it's
so many years
late um always want to see it develops
we have this great chance of benefits
that's regenerate itself chances are for
redevelopment on it
um
it's not accounts for the grant's gone
through maybe an officer applied for it
well well done for applying for a grant
if there's money there to be drawn down
someone's done it well don't you
actually you know i think that's already
fragmented a good way forward
it's not the counselor's money
storage is recounted as money okay
so
why is this money not going to be
released
to red earth
from the council
and obviously you brought it forward
from there you know i i can't make a
decision to see them because i've not
seen the comments from the other
well quite is it another more craniosa i
don't know we get
there's an urgency associated with this
in that the contractor would like to get
onto sites to get the work going um and
obviously as a council we share the
ambition for a developed site because
that's why we sold it uh the
we've no idea when we're going to get
clarity from dealer
um
that that might be next week i hope it's
next week we've been pushing for a
response it might be in some weeks time
and what we didn't want to do was have
things delayed even further by not
having the principle of the agreement
established so that should they
prescribe the conditionality
that is acceptable to the contractor and
we negotiate that we can just move ahead
without having to come back to committee
so that's that's why we've come to you
now before receiving that advice
yes
[Music]
yes thank you mr chairman i just come
back to you again john monty
we are then further forward because
we're waiting for their comments yes
as you just leave straight you know
twice now this evening um i personally
would like to see it released to the
developer
i'd like to see this plan application
actually you know it's been approved i'd
like to say progressing forward the
benefit um at present times more
development coming into this area
with that generator with the warp itself
to me it benefits benefit and highly
that's why i support them again and i
have no connection to red earth
developments whatsoever you look through
any records you'd like and i've not
tended for any contracts on there but i
think it's a great scheme that's why i
supported planning and benefit needs
something outside of the box we can't
stay in the past we've got to be forward
thinking i actually look for the future
because
unfortunately a lot of elderly residents
only give it 10 15 years unfortunately
some of those will be going
to a nice place above so you know we've
got to leave something today to see from
want to respond to that yeah
i i i listen to it councilman's comments
of support um
it is an option i guess to the council
but it would be remiss of us not to
point out that there is this claw back
risk that we hadn't necessarily seen in
the first instance if the sites were to
be used for anything other than housing
and admittedly we think that's unlikely
but it is a possibility that that could
happen
the government department could come to
torridge and not the developer in the
current circumstances will repay that
background so that's why i think we have
to bring it to you attention very
briefly
it's the last time again
we have to develop it here now would the
developer would like to work with
tourists as a council
and actually
underwrite
and actually pass the butt from torres
back to the developer now to me going
forward i think
i can't really have to do that but i'm
not the business
but
surely that safeguard storage accounts
if the developer would underwrite i
please if the discussion will be here
we've seen the management not myself
don't know that because it's way above
the council's pay grades but actually
there's an option to push it progressive
forward so i'll see it progress
at least a station to come in for us
just to give some clarity
[Music]
i think that wasn't
sure
outlined the situation the difficulty
that we've got at present was at
first when we were offered the grant we
were told by dela that we'd hit the
conditions of the grant um and therefore
there would be no requirement
uh for us to repay the eight hundred
thousand now the difficulty that we have
now
is that predominantly and not
fundamentally this job was put into
place to make sure housing was delivered
on that site now if housing doesn't come
forward and bearing in mind we have no
control over the site anymore then it
will be torridge district council who
are asked to repay that 800 000
and that is the concern now at present
um do you like have said to us that they
would at the very least uh require a
charge to be put on that property
but it may be
that that more requirements would come
forward so i think from officer's
perspective we're trying to minimize any
risk that torridge at all have to repay
any of that eight hundred thousand grand
and and that that that's what shawn's
and that that's our our concern so until
d-lock confirm the conditions and we can
confirm them to the developer
now when this contract was negotiated
this grant wasn't anticipated
okay and this is how tori went out to
contract torridge told the lab
regardless as to this grant this grant
came forward
post the contract being negotiated so i
think that's one of the points that that
we're making we're not stopping the
development going ahead that that is
within the developers gift but what
we're saying is until we have
confirmation from the government
department as to the conditions that
they're going to set and confirmation
that there is no liability to torridge
in repaying that grant
that we won't draw down the grant but
everything else it's open to the
developer to get on site and start the
development that is not throwing that
george's delays i do want to make that
that that clear to members
i'll come to you on a second coaster but
i understand there was
at least two people behind without the
hands of it i think wisconsin and then
come to the law
thank you that happened okay i'll be
very very just thank you cherry you're
lucky tonight we have two different
little rooms
[Music]
i heard the jewel
and then you say right we're going to
send you further conditions and we will
applaud black money
is this a correct legal curtain can you
revise me in a few straight sentences
and are we at further risk of further
conditionality coming down the line
thank you
so
[Music]
uh increasingly familiar with when
dealing with government departments of
late in that uh the the ballpark does
tend to change a little as you progress
with things well after you've made it
yeah well that's it so but i think what
they are saying is that the delivery of
homes on the scheme isn't implicit in
the groundwater and actually when you
read all the the the uh guidance
associated associated with the grant
everything that's ever been published by
one public state their whole reason to
be is the delivery of poems
and so if you don't deliver homes then
why would why have they given you money
they've just given you money to add
value to your site
um and that goes against their ethos so
whilst it wasn't explicit they are quite
i just like the legal imperfection of
conditional conditionality from a legal
point of view
[Music]
there are two separate matters here i'm
just going to clarify that so there's a
contract between
district council on redder which is
entirely separate
um
in terms of the grant itself it was
explicit because on delivery of housing
absolutely um
when we put the bid application in
that
we were very clear on the amount of
houses that would be delivered on that
side
i think it's very difficult for us to
argue
that that wasn't a condition of the
grant um when it was previously homes
for england and we've submitted the
planning you know the details of the
planning application and the amount of
houses that are coming forward now in
terms of the grant funding itself
deluxe will simply say to us either have
the money or don't comply with our
conditions or don't
you very much
i can't get it put any clearer than that
that's a loss
thank you chair to do anything other
than support the officers and their
opinions and their
would not be proven
i mean it's as simple as that
uh now just to come back to
uh the benefits of benefit and we're
looking at this walkway through the
front which is a great benefit
the working group has struggled with
this trying to get permission to let the
bikes come right from the entire train
go through the site on the base of the
site on this chair in this hallway
and i think that that's
a pity and i think it's short-sighted
i know there are endless reasons as it
is
and they've got to go along the back of
the site along with
not actually on the agenda though that's
not what we're talking about
thank you
someone else behind you have their hand
up
oh sorry
yes coach another and then
i'm going to move this
recommendation because i think it's a
very good report
and sean and stays here
put simply to us the position we're in
and i do remember when
the planet when the site was sold with
all its
maybe say downsides of it the possible
contamination there the work that would
need to be done on the keyboard all that
was taken into consideration
with the price that we sold the site in
the first principles
so that was all known
as things were going on and once the
contract was sent to sell it to redhead
i don't think he was
quite off the market territory
but there was a chance to apply for this
grant without thinking
there's much of a chance again if we got
it
and and it's brilliant enough but it is
tied as sean's head to housing on the
side and we've got to protect our
position and that's all this
recommendation doesn't care and i'm
happy to move the recommendation thank
you catch your language thank you and
then as well
i just don't
really understand this very simple term
i don't really understand what the issue
is
because originally there wasn't a grant
and it was going to be done
so presumably the developer is still in
a position
that he could get started because if the
ground then comes through he would still
receive the brand am i right
thank you chad
i brought you from what i've heard about
this development i'm in support but i
think it's something that benefit me we
need the money to come into the town and
i think
we need to do what we can to push this
forward and castle the golfers spoke
very
passionately but we need to do that
i think that with the ground it does
sound like this is something which has
fortuity come in later
and seems to be a bit of a bonus as i
understand it in simple terms
and i think it's in everyone's best
interests to work together and agree
notwithstanding that it sounds like we
are waiting for additional
conditions to come down to us from from
above and ultimately it's going to be
waiting for that which is going to hold
things up
as far as i see it if the developer is
as committed to develop developing the
site in the manner which has been agreed
and in putting on the site housing
there shouldn't really be an issue with
agreeing to having a land charge but on
the site to ensure that it is used for
that purpose and that we can claim the
money back
in the scenario that
those on high want that money back if
something else is done with it i don't i
don't really see that that should be an
issue
i know an indemnity is being
offered and there's been people said
about underwriting it and all this sort
of stuff that's very good and i'm sure
that'll be correctly received and could
be used as well but an identity is only
worth something for as long as that
party is able to pay
um it's a limited company at the end of
the day so i i think having the land
charge would make would make more sense
um we've got to protect ourselves but we
have got to work with the developer to
get this get this done and i do think
that we are
beholding to something which is beyond
our control and waiting for these extra
conditions to come through
but the way i see it is once we get
those extra conditions
we should be able to agree that if it is
a land charge to go on there if the
developer is committed to developing
this site as they've said and to get
this bonus
they should be happy to agree to that so
as far as i can tell we should be
pushing forward accepting these
recommendations and waiting to get back
from um d-lock on whatever else they may
or may not ask for
thank you
that sounds
[Music]
the recommendation as printed
on item 13
the recommendation
check i call for a recorder voters
you can if you wish
[Music]
you have to have five members in support
of the requirement
so
that's when the golf is asked for a
recorded vote we need a minimum of five
people to
so it's been proposed and it's been
separated from the show of hands in
support of the recommendation
and again
[Music]
or
thank you
okay moving on there julian 14 the
annual report extraordinary scrutiny
based on 55
that's what it says
[Music]
anything
the topics that we've covered in the
overview and schools
meeting the quality of life
everything that we've discussed
and
scrutinized and made recommendations we
listen to different people all of those
topics have covered all of our quality
of life whether it's from our babies
i don't think there's too many we've
missed
and we will have a full board planned
so i want to thank
the team for supporting me as well
with confidence for my first 12 months
and an hour into my
thank you everything all that five and
15 petitions there are no specific
petitions number one
item 16
no this is a motion
uh we've got two the first one from the
council of four and then from country
christian question
yeah
rest assured
this is
not political you probably are aware
at present or two very serious certain
times
and i know pbs kept probably gonna solve
that but i think
with what's happening i will just face
it that we've got to try to work with
other local authorities
because at the moment it's not
compulsory
i really like to say
where we are now that we haven't had one
actually the only way to fight
nobody we have to change but why did we
not do better
because i will just name under the folks
every once i don't do that wrong
obviously
leader that then have freeze
um 21 years of children conservative
three days he made an older man when he
was under investigation that's what very
serious it's all factually correct
alright
so it's not it's just about doing the
right thing yeah
now i actually forget
my behavior as time went through the
iraq what we're thinking about there so
i might have been dealt with this has
been poorly going forward so i'm not
going to get a second there because all
i'm asking is that dialogue
meaningful dialogue with other countries
you know councils foreign
[Music]
i am
genuinely surprised we don't have dbs
checks i think we're
you know upstanding members of the
community signing people's passports are
in charge of finances potentially going
out visiting schools working with
children seeing vulnerable adults
personally i don't understand why we
didn't have an opt-in dbs
published on our website which i think
is similar to stephen county if i'm
correct
um
i've accepted it
thank you
so um could i report money further i'll
put a label on this but let's talk
personality one side surely there's
another four people one of myself
looking out here when we call involved
please
yeah
or just it
sorry
sorry
i didn't make important i should have
realized it's not for debate notice
emotions so there can't be any questions
i don't think there was an actual
requirement for counselors to be tbs
check if you have a dbs check it is all
voluntary i mean personally i you know i
i
find myself an agreement with catching
forward i think it would be
it would be it would well with whoever
is proposing this i mean it is a good
idea to have a dbs check for the very
reasons that have been i i personally
don't have
[Music]
[Music]
i spoke up and said i think it's in
members interest to actually do it but
then we have no powers to import it
but what i can do is when we have
discussions with other councils i would
explore what their policy is that's how
they deal with it but i really don't see
why people don't do it
because it's done
i'm
not second in your emotion and emotional
support but i will pursue the foreign
[Music]
okay
christopher manley
um
just to clarify hey some people don't
know even though you may have gotten
through this check and i've got fine
if i haven't got one for the choice of
council it has to be relevant to the
organisation that you're
working for volunteering with this
so it wouldn't have to be one specific
to tvc
not to the scandals
am i writing an understanding
from an officer level if any counter
wishes to have a dbs check
tori's officers are happy to facilitate
that for them so you don't have to go
online and do anything themselves they
will do it for you you really have to
read it through and then sign it yeah
that's right that's correct so
it is a relatively easy process i mean
if you try to do it online yourself it
is not an easy process and i have tried
and i have had vbs checks
in the past
so
sorry catch the food ask for a recorded
vote so we need and we shall round in
support of the recorded developments
yeah well that's well enough that's
easily carried so it's been proposed and
seconded
that
let me just check what the
recommendation was again
[Music]
well that's basically wrong along the
lines yeah what
okay dialogue okay so it's been proposed
seconded that we go along the lines that
council of james has outlined that we
explore what other councils do in
relation to their dbs checks correct
yeah okay
people's been seconded several show
values in favor
all right
it's a recording film
throughout the sound of the
thank you chair that's about two
four
councillor bright for councillor brown
or councillor bushby or councillor
christie
councillor clark or chancellor cottle
hunking or councillor craigie or
councillor ford
or councillor gab
or councillor hackett or
councillor haines or councillor harding
[Music]
hutchins
oh no i'm sorry
councillor james or
cancer jones or councillor langford or
councillor laws or councillor leader or
councillor
thank you
thank you again
thanks second notice of motion i can
always say country questioning
thank you
well i sit on the planning committee and
it's uh
it's not a committee where you can bring
up uh new motions and things and we
which is why i brought this to you now
um
if you sit on the planning committee you
get a whole list of statutory console
teams
uh highways you know all those sort of
things one of them is southwest water
and
they very rarely say anything
to be honest they just
pass it and the reason they pass it is
their only duty is to connect
the new houses the sewage system
obviously they get more income from that
i think we're all aware of the recent uh
furore over
releases of sewage into our rivers and
coastal waters
and uh
this motion seeks to address it
because the first bit there we asked
officers to obtain it four surgery
releases in the torridge district
because the only one only figures i've
seen so far relate to the whole of
southwest
and they are not good for southwest
water you won't see them i think they're
the worst aren't they um
so i would like just to accept that
uh i would also ask what's the current
carrying capacity of cornbread
about 10 years ago a joint working group
was set up between torridge and north
demon council
to look in to the state of water
in northern devon
i chair
we wrote to southwest water at that time
and i said what is the carrying capacity
of congress they wouldn't tell us
they have been privatized you can't put
a free information thing into them but i
would like to know because clearly
you've all seen the local plan you all
know how many houses meant for your
parishes
and yet
there seems to be nothing
to tell us can that suit work to
actually come
you may recall some of you jane whisker
you said bradley bring up the issue of
surcharging drains ignore them it was a
huge problem
and that was a few years ago and the
third one is the most interesting one i
think because i think we should ask
southwest water
to produce an impact statement for these
very large estates we're getting just
what is the impact that have been on
emergency releases of sewage because
we keep passing them
they keep taking the money and yet we
still have the problem
and so that's my
three aspects to that and i hope you
would support it now
yes ma'am yeah because holds them
thank you i'd like to second that motion
the coaching four has already done that
all right
[Music]
i'd say that because oh my god before i
was long tolerance in cancer i was
interested
paris councillor and shepwash
and we were told
that
we perhaps had five years
to develop and supply
of sewage treatment in that village
and since then a large number of
applications have been passed in that
marriage and each time
we're told that yes uh
[Music]
so i would like a bigger picture to know
exactly what was going on because what
goes in the cheap one comes out from
yesterday anyway so you may as well know
how to complete things
rather than just well
i i suspect the same could be said for
most of the parishes
they would all be in the same boat but
i don't know how well
i don't know how you would ask that
question that they provided my response
for all that i think that would i don't
think we'd ever get a response if we
widened it too much
i think we need to because we're asking
with each individual application
what each parish should have they must
know
oh i think we'll give response anyway
we can't actually change the numbers of
motion that's that's in front of us now
but in fact you know depending on the
response to this we could then
potentially you could put another
numbers bush and then at another day
yeah i think it's an excellent idea
i think the planning committee every
time we get a planning application
ron just see southwest water no comment
we can actually ask them that what is
the carrying capacity within that parish
yeah all excellent
uh suggestions and i'm sure i'd be very
surprised if there's anyone i need to
center using it tonight so being
proposed by council of christie
settlement before
everyone in support
and again
[Music]
okay there are no
part two items though